hey everyone Superman has been
reportedly recast by the Warner Brothers
Studio with Henry Cavill no longer
attached to the role and rumors just
rumors that Michael B Jordan who played
kill monger of course in Black Panther
might just be in talks to take over the
role of kal-el
look at DC trying to stay relevant for
all the wrong reasons well welcome to
New York starts news this our deep dive
into all the biggest stories this week
so we're also going to talk about this
new daredevil season 3 trailer plans for
an all-female Avengers and Marvel phase
4 question mark venom and more I'm Erik
Bosse we made this table our Maude
Garrett and Philip Malina hi Eric hi
everyone it's so good to be back yo shed
is like a holiday mm-hmm I feel like I'm
still on holiday I'm just gonna stretch
this out to last all year round it's
after Labor Day though so the mobs are
waiting for me outside and in the
comments section yeah yeah but I could
show you those it's a sin all right
let's start with our top story
explaining this craziness with Superman
and Henry Cavill and here's what
happened Warner Brothers was negotiating
with cavil Steen to get him to cameo as
Superman in the upcoming Shazam movie
which is set to come out in April but
talks broke down perhaps because the
studio won't commit to another
standalone superhero Superman movie
after Justice League performed below
expectations and general the studio
sounds like they're you know hitting the
reset button on some of the previous DC
plans so now the reports are that cavil
is officially parting ways from the role
of Superman and cavil actually was just
announced to star in the upcoming
Netflix series The Witcher meanwhile it
sounds like Warner is shifting to their
focus to a Supergirl movie which would
be an origin story featuring her as a
teenager and that would make Clark Kent
in this timeline still an infant that's
the problem with community to another
adults cavil Superman movie it was also
reported that the studio is considering
a completely different shift and
direction for the character maybe even
considering Michael B Jordan in the role
down the road at least maybe not in an
upcoming movie just he might be among a
lot of people that they're looking at to
me the most confusing part of this story
was that Instagram video that Henry
Cavill posted I think we have it here
let's let's roll it and take a look
[Music]
mm-hmm I get that as much as I get most
Instagram stories the fair yeah she
commented on this cuz I saw it and I was
like what are you playing at mr. Supes
and I can't it be like what does it mean
no response even after all those ins
well I I mean I don't know how much of a
breakdown we can really do of this he is
wearing a Krypton lifting team shirt and
yeah I can and the the lip is real here
the chin lifts there's I guess he's
holding like a Superman toy from Justice
League there to me maybe he's like
trolling all of us saying like
regardless of what the barking the media
is doing I'm still Superman but you know
that's kind of a pretty good poker face
there I can't he also loves his dog
whose dog bear oh yeah but I think it's
just a guy who is just like let me play
a song don't care which one and then
hold up a thing and maybe I think he
like didn't mean anything assuming
people like us would go digging into it
don't try to find me mean problem when
you go vague like this like some of the
ideas that people are bringing from this
it's just a little bit ridiculous and
it's like they're they're reading into
it this thing you know it's like he's
trolling us all which I don't even know
if he would do that I don't understand
it's not sophisticated enough to be a
troll technically I would say it's quick
though obviously there's a crypto movie
coming that's why the dogs barking it's
a super dog super yeah man script
something yeah I don't know I guess my
question is would we even be in the
scenario if Warner Brothers just gave us
a true sequel to Man of Steel as opposed
to having to immediately force them into
BVS and then Justice League I mean
alternate realities right something we
could easily say like no we wouldn't
because now he'd be further cemented as
Man of Steel but what if it was like one
movie deeper in the hole that they feel
they've built and I know that right now
they're trying to pretend that like the
previous movies are like we're not
married to those movies
kind of trying to rewrite history
already so one movie deeper could have
been a problem actually sir and much
harder thing that they just need to
reboot from unless it had been Wonder
Woman you know I mean and then it's game
changing it's like this guy was gonna
play Superman until he's 80 yeah I don't
I don't know they would have solved it
you know Steve Trevor was the big part
of Wonder Woman and those two in their
chemistry was amazing but yeah I would
much rather sort of see a pairing
instead of this whole group ensemble
that would keep getting from DC which is
rushed in you're not fleshing out these
characters enough I'm loved Amy Adams as
an actor I just don't love her
as yeah and I would I would actually
prefer to see Superman and Wonder Woman
team-up I think those two together well
so in yen the new 52 like that's a real
hot relationship Buffy and Spike kind of
yeah except for there's one really
awkward but aside from that when two
super-powered people go at it it's kind
of like the dream I was like Jessica
Jones and Luke 8 I like my parents
I think being so hard and you know not
even going with Superman anymore that's
disgusting rather okay but going into
Antonio was made house was destroyed my
conception like it's just one house
going Supergirl is a bit risky now I
think that pivoting Superman's character
and casting someone like Michael B
Jordan is a huge it's like really
refreshing it's something that's new and
exciting I know that it was a Nicholas
Scott I think was an artist who did
already kind of played around with
finger science and in any designs Oh
looks great I just heard on Twitter
today there was like an image where
someone was like yeah we've been
thinking about this for a while now and
I was like I love it it looks really
sick and you know I feel like with
spider-man we had Miles Morales it's not
it's not Peter Parker it's a completely
different character but it's the same
superhero in a way that's all in the
same spot so you're saying that you
would essentially like what I do and not
be Clark Kent yeah Superman yeah yeah
yeah that'd be that'd be one way this is
going completely like you said they were
going fresh clean they're cleaning the
slate that could be
a way to do it yeah so the elephant in
the room right is like mod stress
matches our nearest colors way too well
no it's the dress right no so is is the
the race change right and I just want to
acknowledge that like we're not blind to
it and that I even personally I had a
like status check when I heard that and
I was like huh and it took about 30
seconds so I was like okay you know any
words it was like for a second and
honestly when I when I was going huh it
wasn't even so much race it was also
like isn't he like not that tall and a
little like skinny and it's you know
what I mean like it was like kind of
like a visual check in and then I was
like well he beefed up actually I don't
really see the difference like I don't I
mean and I'm gonna get eaten alive by
some people about it but I don't know
it's like if it's been around for 75
years and Superman he's white at the end
of the day he's an alien as well so it's
right here that he is white like a
Kansas or something like like honestly
what what about his appearance is tied
to being a white dude with a black girl
I mean we've seen it before already with
Hawaii in the stage play she's right
back that is the creator JK Rowling
choosing to recast the characters black
me probably honestly in retrospect
remembering like hey you know now that I
think about it yeah I I like Michael B
Jordan a lot I don't know if just
looking purely at his acting style I
don't really see a kal-el just in
because he just brings so much emotion
like I loved the way he played kill
monger and there was so much like but
that could be such so depression right
like that American teenager or American
alien thing where it's like a version of
Clark Kent that is emotional and intense
and kind of is like you know what Tom
Welling that's the issue right so with
Smallville Tom Welling tried to play an
angsty Superman but they had to cast
someone that looked like this guy yeah
and you know those people that was
putting appearance before acting chops
and no offense the guy I liked him but
there was no nuance he just bit
you know and then like laser beams that
would be heat beams but that would be
what would be the the emotion instead of
like Michael B Jordan as kill monger you
kind of are like I think I agree with
you and I'm sad for your death yeah you
were the bad guys
the next notch on your body we're also
seeing it with The Witcher and I think
it's kind of timely knowing that Henry
Cavill is going to be playing Geralt of
Rivia but knowing that ciri who is an
iconic character in the third game it's
basically like almost which is adopted
daughter again white hair white skin
super leg Scandinavian because it's all
said in like the ancient Nordic times
and they're going to cast that well the
casting went out and they're looking for
beam which is I think black Asian or
minority minority ethnic ethnicity so
they're looking for someone who's not
why and again man the audience has just
flipped out but it's like it's a
fictional character we've only seen an
iteration in a video game it's like what
can we just think outside the white box
yeah a white person no and if I could
play Sierra I would do it in a heartbeat
so I think it's it's like and again
we're gonna like like your comments are
so on point already people disagreeing
with us and like good for you but for
the people that do agree with us or are
just curious about this other thing it
does have to do with the overall
suspension of disbelief is when you
enter fiction you kind of are in a place
now where it's like I just want good
storytelling and good character and I've
never read a piece of fiction and
thought mmm I like this race you know
unless a story was about exploration of
race and ethnicity like I haven't I
haven't really I pictured whoever like
like I imagined when they say like it
like a so you're reading a book and it's
like the old professor gets in her way
you might imagine a short old white man
is balding and somebody else might
imagine like a Morgan Freeman type like
it's just your imagination it's just
fiction but I also think that you know
because we see the different diversity
we were constantly so used to seeing
white characters and because these
characters were made 75 years ago where
there wasn't much diversity as well it's
like when do we take the steps to kind
of change that or do we honor what the
original source was know
that diversity wasn't really a priority
if it does not matter especially then
yeah I think if this kind of thing
bothers you maybe just take a step back
from yourself if you're capable of doing
that understand that you're just
defaulting to white which is what we've
always just done because that's what
we've seen in media but I be faulted to
white my people can't and call me that
it white default is not it's not a flaw
that you have like by choice it's it's
just you know it's Dafoe's yeah it's
just an exposure things like media has
been white forever so it's like yeah I
default to why I even default white
everyone kind of defaults away it's like
there's no need to it's not necessary
for the experience I also understand
that it's like you know there are so
many people that could play the white
Superman like it you know there are
people out there it's not that there's
no other choice and that's why we're
thinking outside the box I understand
that there are a number people that
could do a really good job as Superman
as a Caucasian Superman I just I don't
know it's it's interesting just to marry
those two together so heavily yeah
there's um and you know what Michael B
Jordan was just one name in a deadline
report it doesn't mean it's the one
person there considering right now I
think they just gave an example someone
like we could also go in this direction
they said like they're I assume they're
huge studio they're probably looking at
like your army hammers and you're Oscar
Isaacs and whoever else you imagine the
part yeah and you know it's what's I
think they're even doing with that I
think maybe there's obviously there's
like a wink to the fact like hey we're
even open to diverse casting for this
but I think actually the message being
sent is like let's we could reinvent
this character a bit because here's
something that really freaking sucks for
Henry Cavill he's really good actually
he's a very mission impossible he is my
favorite character in his recent one
reloading his arms yeah
but then also in Man From UNCLE he's
like he's really good to her this guy's
charming he's so when they haven't
placed Superman it's not his choice to
play it a bit wooden a bit muted
whatever it's their interpretation of
that character so I think honestly
that's what I'm more excited about her
reacting to is like oh that would be
like a completely different take on
Superman
that I'm excited about because it's been
a while since we have had a Superman who
you know did not like getting shot in
the eye
Brandon yeah Brandon rather it's just
like Melton is I want to well let us
know what you think about Henry Cavill
leaving do you think he how do you think
his acting messed with the character of
Superman and keep things civil when it
comes to any other discussion of
possible other supermen but for now we
actually want to share something with
you that we're very very excited about
new rock stars is actually branching out
to a whole new place where for the first
time ever you'll be able to watch
something with us while we break it down
this is called scenar
it's a chrome extension and you know
it's really perfect for the type of
in-depth commentary that we do here but
you know rather than watching our like
condensed retelling of movies and TV
series here on YouTube scene er overlays
our commentary on anything that you're
streaming as you watch it so you're kind
of just seeing it in real time and you
don't have to like interrupt your your
watching we're just kind of there with
you pointing out stuff and you know it's
not just our commentary your commentary
is involved with this to senior lets you
give your take on the shows and movies
that you love to watch by synching your
reaction videos alongside what you're
watching in the same browser so with
scenar you can create share and watch
video commentary synchronized with
streaming shows movies and clips from
Netflix Hulu and YouTube and you don't
have to worry about copyright issues
like we do that legitimately cost us
like a lot of money sometimes dealing
with that yeah and it prevents us from
being able to do certain kinds of things
yeah yeah it's amazing so here's what
you got to do just go to see nerd comm
slash new rock stars on your desktop
computer to watch with us so our new
rock stars channel has a commentary
breakdown that I did actually on Doctor
Strange plus another one coming out
pretty soon that I'm exciting on a very
relevant one to conversation yeah
and I just love all this because I get
to like throw these nerdy details at you
from up in the corner at the precise
moment that happens exactly how I would
want to watch these things that have
this experience with you just right
there with you yeah very often like our
analysis actually has a lot to do with
like at this point in the movie and you
and I have experiences when we're
writing our breakdowns right at this
point if you remember when you were
watching it you're feeling this like
we're like have
to remind you of where you are in the
movie and how you feel about it's like
what if as you're feeling it's like you
feeling really tense right now
that's because listen of the music
that's happening right now you know like
we're have we're having that experience
with you but then also we can have a
whole other experience that we can have
there where you actually just kind of
like hang out with us while we watch
something so I'm dropping pretty soon a
piece of commentary on Breaking Bad
which is one of my favorite pilots
that's ever happened and that pilot
episode is one of the best designed
pilots that you've ever seen and that is
like even a new experience it's not even
like a breakdown we've done before it's
like hang out and watch it with me while
I keep the death out on it and I just
like every single thing I'm like this is
amazing because of this this is amazing
because of this so hopefully you have
seen it before because I will be talking
over that yeah I actually like the that
I do because I know I watched a movie
I'd never seen The Godfather
oh I was sitting like this the full-on
like downtown cinema and everyone got
dressed up and I went with my best
friend Alicia Malone who knows classic
movies better than anyone and she kept
leaning over being like at this moment
and she would tell me like this crucial
detail about behind the scenes or
something about Marlon Brando or just
something yeah I was like this is so
much better like it's another layer
about what's happening that you know
you're learning while watching diggin
and if you don't want it it's like go
away yeah if you want it come back and
turn it off it easily yeah and so
Phillip and I are on there currently
Sam's and BJ flash breakdown that should
be up there so yeah again check out our
channel scenar it's time to make a scene
and if you love what we do here you're
just gonna want to download that scene
or plugin it's super easy to do I just
it's a great way to on the chrome store
specifically right now other place too
soon but we can't talks about it by the
way I've been working on this a lot and
I like just have to say that baby I've
been consulting with this like crazy
because it's like I was like this is
exactly what we need
so I mean you guys know it's really
important to me personally yeah let's go
check it out
and for now let's move on to this week's
trivia question okay so you guys know
the stakes stakes stakes yeah haha baby
takes okay so in a man of steel keeping
things Superman related here in the
movie Man of Steel what was the name of
the Kent family dog
all right all of our answers are here in
the the bucket now later in the show
these names got a we went to the dollar
store for everything on this set yeah
we'll reveal the answer to the question
the closest as decided by a judge will
do or sign off goodbyes at the end of
the video meanwhile the loser will have
to partake in our relatively new trivia
punishment and it will have to be
inducted into the gif of shame of which
I think we're all members so oh the gif
of shame the ghetto yeah cuz you chose
to be another last time I love lucky
inflatable flailing I'm cheap men okay
in other news this week we got a teaser
for daredevil season 3 now it's just a
little awesome clip with Matt Murdock in
a church confessional booth he looks all
bloodied up like he's just been a fight
and he wears his black season 1
vigilante clothes and he says I'd rather
die as a devil than live as Matt Murdock
how did that make you feel saying that I
can do better than that
I'll tell you where you can see me do
impressions superheroes at the end of
the video anyway season this season will
drop most likely sometime before the end
of 2018 we don't have a date yet but
they said hopefully before December and
here's what we know about the story we
know that the defenders were ended with
the image of Matt Murdock waking up and
recovery somehow he survived a building
falling on him and that shot actually
may be familiar to some of you comic
book readers it was taken directly from
the born-again daredevil comics by Frank
Miller and Charlie Cox has said that
season 3 will be largely influenced by
born-again just not a page to page
adaptation he also teased that there
would be another hallway fight one of
the people that choreographs those
recently and I was just like man when
yet and like every single like little
thing I could do he's like oh that was
Bill yeah he like had it in his head
still oh man I was so impressed yeah
that was it Caudill oh god just kind of
improvised in that moment
someone's in the sound booth just
punching a watermelon because that was
just squishy and yeah there's a lot of
texture in that sound well and just in
case those of you who haven't read born
again want to know what it is it's it's
just kind of known as like one of the
best comic book storylines for daredevil
it's very dark and involves kingpin
realizing Daredevils identity and like
destroyed his life Ville becomes
homeless and kind of crazy and there's a
lot of like Christian symbolism going on
and there's a lot of artwork kind of
depicts him as a Christ figure but a
couple implications I want to talk about
one is this one of the big villains that
kingpin unleashes on Hell's Kitchen is
nuke and nuke has kind of been
introduced
through Jessica Jones through will
Simpson these Frank Simpson in the
comics but so he might come back but to
me the more interesting idea is this
idea will this be affected by the snap
will we see the world of Hell's Kitchen
affected by the dusting and maybe that's
why Matt Murdock is another ejected
states heart no I don't think they're
going they're not crossing that stream
just yet but I do think the fact that
you know with the born-again if he's in
that one line where it was just like I
would rather die as daredevil than live
you know as in his human life is that's
if that's taken away from him you know
his identity is learned by kingpin and
that makes absolute sense yeah it's the
comic yeah I think that's why it's so
dark
III also agree that it's probably not
post snap because here's my day I eat my
guess for in general how Netflix decide
to handle it is let's make all of our
heroes have a concurrent story that's
taking place right before infinity war
so you know the new season of Jessica
Jones sort of her like the lady all the
latest seasons are actually agent
they're not running consecutively
they're running concurrently you just
remember a run I think it's in Manhattan
that giant aliens that have the cutting
machine like that has to show up shortly
like yeah yeah which it is there
currently if you go to Disney World I
believe right like you it's in the news
thing whatever
oh yeah the daily
yeah exactly so that's where Disney
World currently is out on the timeline
yeah agents of shield definitely seems
concurrent with this app right because
the finale of the most recent season
they deal with until the moment the snap
itself does not happen yeah it's like
they do deal with Daniels coming yeah I
agree with you Philip I could see that
the dusting may not happen yet it's just
little too soon I'm also trying to think
like when they would have to have shot
this because they kept that pretty under
secret like what would happen and I
don't think they would have let that
spread they're pretty separate the
people who produce the TV series or so
that people produce some movies so I
don't think there would be a lot of
swapping and notes enough to be like
okay we're gonna work in the snap but do
we think that that will ever address it
in these shows because they're pretty
separate Sox's I think no especially in
the Marvel TV shows the only thing you
really get is like you know a kid
dresses Captain America you know those
tiny little inserts that don't really
affect anything at all it's just
reminding and acknowledging that the
heroes do exist in that world it seems
like they've been given permission to
mention the Battle of New York from
Avengers but like that was like six
years ago
why are they bigger events of Henson I
also think that they probably weren't
sure where they wanted to draw that line
and so you know initially there actually
were a few more references to the green
guy like that but then it feels like
they've liked since backtracked on that
I wonder if part of it had to do with
the idea that Disney was like we're
gonna launch our own streaming service
how much do we want Netflix this stuff
to be essential viewing in order for you
to have a complete experience of the MCU
yeah I mean it's frustrating because
it's like well then why are you doing it
in the same universe if you're not gonna
take advantage of that yeah it's I'm
like one foot in one foot out what's
like x-men a little bit oh it's like
okay so it's all Marvel but these
characters can never meet and it's like
they're not really gonna interact it's
like you take away what is the best
value in trade of the Marvel Universe is
that these characters could meet and
team up and like form new relationships
or with twelve characters and let's talk
about the future of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe always always we have a first
look at Captain Marvel
last week and we know that she will play
a decisive role in the showdown against
Thanos and oven
for and Marvel head Kevin Feige revealed
that the studio has many movies actually
in the near future that will be female
lead
so that female superhero movies
hopefully will no longer be like a
novelty they'll actually just be the
norm and people will be able to look
past you know their gender it's like
white default right it's also a man
default one of the reasons why and this
I'll throw a bone real quick start
interrupt date I'll throw a bone real
quick to the people that are often
talking about like like women
complaining about about their portrayal
where I actually I had a click moment
recently where I was watching upgrade
which is amazing actually and I would
give that my shout out upgrades a really
cool movie but it opens with a classic
like oh no a woman got hurt and now the
man has to do something about it and it
was one of the first times I was like
man I feel that that actually felt a
little old and Ike stale when I saw that
moment and then I realized no from a
writing perspective it's not that she's
a woman that needs to get hurt it's that
you want your main character to suffer
their worst possible loss the thing that
they love the most and and there's
nothing wrong with saying romantic
relationships are the most important
thing in many people's lives or their
children but even even sometimes say not
even that and so that you take away who
they love the most it often happens to
be a woman but that's where the problem
is right cuz of man default
every every hero is a man every story
has a lead man no it's called a super
hero not a super heroine right exactly
people treat it that way right so it's
like so I'm the reason I'm saying I was
throwing a bone is like I don't actually
agree where it's like when women are
like Oh
once again the woman gets hurt because
men love to torture women it's like no
it's actually a writing thing but on the
other side I'm like but we need more
female leads than be the stars of things
yeah for sure
what kind of a female lead movies could
[ __ ] been referring to specifically
well who's been mention of course
Captain Marvel has her movie coming out
in March and remember there is a black
widow movie in development most recently
with Kate Shortland announced as a
director besides that Feige has hinted
at a possible Miss Marvel Kamala Khan
movie she would be the first Muslim
superhero on the big screen
I'm also gotten clues that Karen Gillan
and nebula and Karen Gillan from Karen
Gillan the actually saying that nebula
and mantis might be teaming up in a
future Marvel installment probably
Avengers 4 but who know
could you guys see an all-female
Avengers and if so which of them would
you want to see in there my concern
would be like oh we're just doing what
Ghostbusters did or oceans they might
have double backlash from that like the
preacher's female but I would basically
with these characters they're doing what
DC's doing birds of prey is happening
hunger Rob right yeah you know
pioneering that one with Holly and
poison ivy and I think that's kind of
Marvel following DC for the first time
which is yeah interesting yeah I don't
think it's like those because it's not
like they're saying like let's pretend
the whole universe didn't happen and now
it happened this other way with women
and whoa it's very similar you know like
like I don't think it's that I think
it's kind of your birds for example yeah
there's perfect where it's like you know
our female characters are good enough to
put together - absolutely I mean the
other ones that are established just to
run through mirror there's wasp and
Scarlet Witch Sharia coy a Valkyrie and
then also Maria hill and Pepper Potts MJ
and Gamora Jessica Jones if you want to
bring her in Elektra Jane Foster there's
a lot of like different mixes and
matches any four of those with a couple
exceptions watch the movie with the oh
you mean they should well they'll
probably come back I mean we're gonna
have another spider-man movie I know
this well but someone who specifically
died well non does no one specifically
died infinity where I know people
watched my eight Loki resurrection video
yeah well no an issue right like a body
that fell is not necessarily a body that
died but of these I'm gonna say and not
just these but of established characters
I would have said Valkyrie is someone
who I think could play like such an
awesome role but since Valkyrie is
already there and we already mentioned
Valkyrie I'm gonna go and say that a
character not established yet and I'm
just like super wild card and I don't
know why this came to mind but I would
love to see post-merger mystique find a
way in and it's not like not of not a
version is like always been a hero like
a person who's like been problematic
whatever but like a troublemaker
shapeshifter something that we haven't
seen that much of also I kind of feel
like Scarlett wish which got nerfed
so I also wouldn't mind seeing like Jean
Grey but yeah
fallaway to Jean Grae going head to head
or like doc Phoenix but yeah some
redundancy with the x-men for sure
because I think how come on the con is
also a shapeshifter and there's some of
the like shape-shifting stuff personally
just because I know mystique a little
bit more I'd be more curious to see I
don't know how much sleepiness I like a
villain playing a role
yeah for sure yeah and you know we
haven't seen she-hulk now is she hooked
tied him with like the Hulk properties
we're only Universal can do is she holds
so I I don't know I did look that up a
long time ago and it was one of these
things where they're they're not they
don't have clear answers in the public
side but I I honestly I also thought she
Hulk and honestly that one of the
reasons why I think they wouldn't is
because she looks so much like tomorrow
we already got a green person yeah it's
not easy being green wasn't there
something else with like a green skin
characters and they're like I would be
too similar to oh I guess Drax was
supposed to be kind of green in the
comics and they they changes a little
bit yeah but let us know which of uh
which of these characters including oh
yeah we're forgetting Susan storm we're
hopefully you see a fantastic or reboot
Susan storm is surrounded and flanked by
three other men and she's the wife
usually let's be honest to you and yet
she's like like huge power it's the same
thing that was like Scarlet Witch where
it's like your powers are so much cooler
than they're showing up in the movies
yeah shield I'm the protector let's move
on to another quick update here it was
announced this week that Westworld
season 3 will add Aaron Paul to the cast
in an unknown bro apparently he will be
a series regular though Paul of course
played just a pink been on Breaking Bad
he voices Todd on Bojack horseman it's
great show new season just came out and
just to remind us of how season 2 of
West Road ended Dolores led Bernard and
Charlotte I'm going to well plug your
just in case well get in a detail
basically there are boundaries of the
park have maybe been surpassed right
like there's some of the hosts who are
working their way out into the to the
world of human beings that's cool so I'm
kind of curious like my first thought
was Aaron Paul as kind of this Gary
Oldman from Rise of the Planet of the
Apes right where he
was that riser dawn dawn I think where
he was like kind of the leader the human
resistance when the robots are starting
to take over I could kind of seem being
like this oh you're like jumping pretty
ahead creating militias against becomes
kind of a Secret Invasion kind of thing
of like who is Rio host I mean it's
impossible to really tell it's like
things so slow on that show I think you
just described it especially season 2
yeah it's still yeah it's it's a show
about ideas more than a show about like
a immediate payoff for sure but let us
know what what kind of part you'd love
to see her and Paul play he's a great
actor he wouldn't I forget that he won
the Emmy three times for playing Jesse
right yeah okay so the reason why is
because I was really set to watch all
five seasons of Breaking Bad and then
someone told me the finale ending and I
was just like cool and I figured nothing
can smoke spoil me as bad as that but I
didn't think Jesse Pinkman was I didn't
think Aaron did a good job in the first
he gets a lot better actually and I
think I asked an acting teacher work
with them throughout the series yeah
he's kind of like a I feel like they
didn't know they're gonna go that far
with the character at the start of the
series right and then by the end just
they started to like how he was playing
with the part well he was supposed to be
killed off actually by the one that
makes sense because the way the
breakdown that's coming on had this on
that episode we have all kinds of
information like that on scene that's
cool both Aaron Paul and Dean Norris I
feel like our two characters that were
like Hankin and Jesse or comic relief in
the pilot and the way their characters
evolved it was the series is so
fascinating I think I'm stuck on season
four I actually get anxiety when he's
house he opens it up to anyone
oh yeah it's a crack then that's also a
good time we get badger comedy theater
that Eric and I used to run around at
but which actually became game that's
right okay Matt Jones is a great
character on Breaking Bad a very very
funny performer comedy former improviser
at the place that I was just referencing
I just remembered we just find out
turned into like a crack den yeah
remember my Improv Theater closed the
Wesley on Hollywood Boulevard that led
to the race but not all them were doing
drugs some of them were just homeless it
became an artist true community some of
them were doing drugs some of them were
selling guns out of their selling gun
which it's not it's mostly a safety
thing because there's another thing up
in Oakland where people doing that
beholding burn yeah I never saw 59
people on their own okay let's move on
venom tickets are now on sale with the
movie released in a couple weeks and it
was confirmed that the movie will be
rated pg-13 it was kind of a question
before it was decided we learned in
order to set the stage for a possible
crossover with spider-man in a future
film director Ruben Fleischer also
confirmed that there will be a
post-credits the Instagram through the
credits not like we have to tell you to
do that this actually could be where
Sparta mate appears maybe where carnage
appears it sounds like it would probably
carnage wouldn't spider-man we would
have probably heard from Tom Hollands
himself if he showed like I can't tell
you but I am in it taboo and you're just
like orange orange you glad I'm in this
we received this poster that you looking
at me behind behind my shoulder is the
final poster for the movie there maybe
there'll be others it's kind of Jackson
Pollock style spray of paint
showing Venom's face and you know making
sure to keep that hashtag in front of
venom because you know there's no other
way the word venom it's gonna trend on
Twitter it's real clever I can't ask you
guys how much do you think we should
trust the market in this movie when it
comes to building up our expectations is
there a good movie behind the trailers
of this movie and the posters yeah
potentially III even though I'm like way
less excited than I was at one point I
love Tom Hardy and almost everything
that Tom already does even if I just
watch it as I'm not an actor I don't
care about acting from a performer side
but from like I get impressed by people
they can sing like Whitney Houston I get
impressive girl that can transform these
characters kind of like Tom Hardy if you
watch a movie where he drives the whole
time oh yes it's just him in a car the
whole time that's all
but then there's other one where he
looks like your friend Joel it was the
boxer Bronson yeah yeah
I in like like these are such and the
bane right like it like he's just this
transform bigger but like kind of still
in every man so for that reason there's
no way I'll miss this but I'm less
excited than I used to be there's kind
of this weird like fan reaction of
things where it's like oh Tom Hardy's
making a vocal choice so I cringe at
that I find that awkward it's like or
he's just making a character choice with
his voice and if there wasn't a trailer
for this he would just walk in the movie
be like acting yeah interesting yeah
alright but also like if you want the
r-rated one Watch upgrade that's like
exactly what I found where I was like
the the lead looks like Tom Hardy think
I need to know immediately Devon can you
pull up a shirtless pic I just Ramadi
and then I it's also about essentially
like a symbiote kind of thing taking
someone's body over it's kind of like
extra abilities and in him like being
like a little lost by that it feels like
even feels like the venom trailer and
that movie so good that it actually did
make me more excited again for I was
like well venom then if it does this
it'll be good yeah but that's an r-rated
one are you gonna see it opening night
though cuz I think I'm gonna wait and
then you guys tell me if it's good or
not and then i'll yeah i know i can't do
not see me at opening night it's a thing
yeah we want to get those breakdowns for
you fast yeah but also the experience
right i have a thing for the with the
director and writer wanted from its
audience and I think for movies like
this they want you there opening night
yeah I want you to have that experience
before cheering like yeah so I get that
- its kind of fun of it yeah yeah yeah
and you know way like when it comes to
the pg-13 versus R rating its we talked
about this before they the character of
venom as he was first introduced in the
comics was not necessarily r-rated his
evolution over time did go to some
r-rated places it was really carnage was
the more r-rated of the two of them
right it's it's like a juggernaut being
a cannibal technically should I mean
like in like stories it's like well do
we feel like juggernaut has been in
r-rated movies so a very pg-13
juggernaut as well an x-men
say right in an x-men and then you know
this boiler in another movie but yeah
like he you don't have to have that
portrayal for certain characters yeah I
mean like did like spawn or something
like these are characters that are just
like knowing murderers yes seem by it
now by the right guys you can't spell
that without by yeah and you know and
when this movie comes down a couple
weeks we'll definitely be there with the
post-credits scene explanation and
breakdowns and bunch of videos I mean
I'm still excited a visual effects so
this movie just look exactly as I would
want I hope so yeah we'll see now it's
time to move on to our New York sirs
news lightning round
I heard Scott's everyone being affected
by the hurricane currently but still
lightning round it's a lightning storm
there's no rain associated you guys we
have some questions we have firing them
at my co-host I gotta answer them as
quickly without hesitation as possible
are we ready not even a little bit
Walmart its ownit you first at Cappy kid
wants to know what's your spirit animal
Oh wolf or a flamingo probably a
flamingo but I want it to be wolf you
gotta get one of these shirts flamingos
my spirit animal - there's a bunch of
them and these are actually flamingos
they're just floating in front of it
they'll flap away at some point Phil oh
yeah Alberto plaz wants to know what
would be a wrestling name - opium -
troops stream-of-consciousness
topic Erik oh this one I Eric at David
for Elle wants to know what was your
favorite non comic-book movie of the
summer
ooh of the summer Mission Possible fall
out but I do want a shout-out at Barnaby
black whoa one wants to know if you
think dearth mail will get his own movie
either rain or shine be there with a
double-bladed envelope right there okay
well now it comes a time for every
second shoutouts reaches is 15 seconds
to shout out plug a rail about anything
in the world
fill up why you start I'm super proud of
seeing her I'm working on it it's still
in development if you have ideas
definitely let me know but please check
it out it means a lot to me but to us
also in rockstars I think it could be
anything I think could be like that big
I think it's a new platform so if you go
to senior comm slash new rockstars get
the Chrome extension but also like like
upload stuff and like find ways to like
like innovate like stuff that I haven't
haven't done with you guys but I just
like was playing around with I mean the
scene we were talking about a second ago
where we were saying the the watermelon
being punched or whatever like in senior
you could show oh what the watermelon
being punched in the upper corner like
it doesn't have to be commentary could
be like anything recreations of the
thing you're watching or Dever I'm just
like this is a new platform please check
it out also you talked about upgrade
twice if I still don't know what it is
can you extend your 15 seconds and just
tell me about upgrade yeah it's just
like a notification on the upper right
of your screen and it's just kind of
like you want to do it tonight or
upgrade the movie oh I've been this
whole time I've been talking about Mac
OS TV if you wanna if you want to watch
it or on iTunes or anywhere you can buy
like rent a movie or whatever but it's
literally just called upgrade and it's
about a guy who gets a chip implanted in
his head and it gives his body abilities
not because it adds abilities but
essentially it's like I'm a computer I
can run your body way better than you
can yeah okay
I thought my day was gonna be made guess
not he'll pull it up for you or he'll
take your shirt off devyn dick you sure
wait that's not the first time we've
ever do that kind of stuff on this
channel please yeah yeah um okay so my
15 second shot is to geek pumps power
playing watching reading which I'm going
to use for this because I don't have one
thing that I want to necessarily shout
out so I'm just gonna tell you what I'm
playing watching and reading I'm playing
stardew valley on my
Macbook I am watching all of Doctor Who
again and I'm reading order of the
Phoenix by Harry Potter I'm saying it
goes meanwhile Neville Longbottom is
like the true star he's working on it so
yeah what a writer now I actually match
this back because my face is red there
you go alright for my 15 seconds I'm
gonna talk to you about a live comedy
show that I'm doing at the end of this
month in Los Angeles it's called step on
the screen infinity fan it's a live fan
edit somatic universes oh they're all in
there baby it's a comedy sketch show
parody in the stuff we talked about this
channel yes includes the adventures and
Star Wars game of Thrones Harry Potter
Deadpool the DC Universe you know a
bunch of characters I probably don't
have the licensing to do but it's a
parody so I get to do it which ones do
you have the license in - oh god gets
sued by Eric yeah name one I'll play all
of them just some simple Deadpool oh I'm
gonna do a bunch of dick jokes and some
of them are gonna be offensive a little
too offensive namely hey kid I'm glad
you two ended up together you of my
favorite bearing I'm actually not
playing Stanley there's no right way to
do well here's like some stuff it's
about a nerdy fanboy who tries to fix
all this stuff even when it doesn't need
to be fixed in some cases he just makes
them more so like would Han Solo want to
be resurrected should George are Martin
really finished Game of Thrones well is
Harry Potter actually better off with
his parents murdered it's gonna answer
some of those questions and you know
write about it so this is a show I'm
starring in it you'll get to see me
dance and sing really poorly you also
get to see Tommy Bechtold mr. bottom
line himself bunch other hilarious
people that I know here in LA it's
Saturday September 29th 9 p.m. Acme
comedy theater in North Hollywood
tickets are only 5 bucks and if you get
them online you can find him on the
link in the description below and I'll
be tweeting about a bunch so yeah you
know I gotta find the comedic outlet for
some of this stuff you know I do a
little bit in the videos but you know
what I wanted to do it live and you come
in come talk to me afterwards and man as
Wolverine and Logan as Wolverine and
Logan Logan Hugh Jackman and Logan so
this is what it feels like
better be funnier than that no it's
exactly that
one man farts and everyone works yep
okay so yeah check it out and and
hopefully if you live in LA or you can
come watch it but finally let's return
to the trivia question that we asked
earlier and reminder that our punishment
is the gift of shame yeah so the way
this works the wrong stance we'll have
to draw a task from the ship of shame do
it and and though perform that task
repeatedly well the winner gets to read
the goodbyes no chance shame at you it's
so embarrassing you'll be turning to an
animated gif so everyone knows how wrong
you were and you'll be punished online
endlessly so let's remind everyone what
the question is the question did you get
my prize Oh what was the name of the
Kent family dog and Man of Steel I can't
tell you the Kent family dog in Man of
Steel mark thinks it's Jerry my I'm
referencing the creator of Superman and
that's my only guess something like even
if you sure mod leave me be I'm hurting
enough as is trying to say Jerry
is a Cornhusker but I guess it's
Nebraska answer was Hank Hank the dog
nope just Hank it's gotta be there's no
it's just hey it's just hey it's not a
dog's name this is the dog run out of
the storm shelter at some point that's
how jonatha Kenton dies in the movie
gets sucked in by the tornado and it's
Hanks fault
and they blame Hank thanks well who was
yeah start with the continent
Reggie's verdict is unquestionable so
mods got to draw gif of shame shame
shame shame pretend like you've never
seen a microphone before and it's
blowing you mud oh boy okay Shh it's all
do our goodbyes I'll film champagne
alright everyone thank you for watching
this to exception he rocks there's me I
wanna thank our host me Eric's awesome
film Alena and Maude Garrett our new
yes bad hey comment down below tweet us
a new rock stars like this video shared
around subscribe to the rock stars for
our deep dives and all the stuff you
love thanks for watching see you next
week we'll mods mine ever be but good
job models very funny
[Music]